well the Senate may be working this
weekend to try to get an historic bill
passed aimed at stopping the spread of
coronavirus while also helping affected
Americans and a health care system
bracing for potential overload and the
Navy prepares to deploy its to hospital
ships on either coast to help backup
stress medical facilities so let's bring
in a Navy reservist who knows a little
something about those ships Republican
congressman from Indiana Jim banks good
to have you back sir
great to be with you I gotta tell you
it's been really interesting to learn
about the ships my good buddy Dana
Perino has spent a lot of time on them
tries to raise awareness about what
they're doing out there and I know that
you at one point we're part of a mission
supporting the mercy ship which is going
to be going out a popular mechanics
describes the ship this way it says at
full strength each ship has a crew of 71
and up to 1200 doctors nurses and other
medical specialists 12 fully equipped
operating rooms a thousand bed hospital
facility digital radiological services
medical lab pharmacy and the list goes
on and on tell us what these ships are
capable of well Shannon one of my very
favorite experiences serving in the Navy
Reserves was supporting the mercy as you
said in a in a visit to East Timor in
2016 right before I became a member of
Congress I got to see firsthand what the
men and women do on these hospital ships
we have two of them that mercy and the
comfort they've served over a half a
million people in countries around the
world since 2001 they export goodwill as
part of their humanitarian efforts
around the globe - and providing
healthcare to those who need it and now
president Trump has called them to serve
us here at home during this crisis and
the pandemic due to the corona virus
what I saw in East Timor in 2016 though
were the 1,200 doctors and nurses and
the men and women who make up the the
United States Navy those those who serve
in the Navy who serve on the on the
mercy what they do the huge logistical
effort that goes into deploying these
ships is it's amazing opportunity for us
to show Americans what they do I'm one
who believes survey on the Armed
Services Committee Shannon that we have
two of these hospital ships I'm a
proponent that we have many more of them
I believe we need a fleet of a dozen
more of these hospital ships to go
around the world and show off the best
of what America has to offer and when we
need them to to help us here at home
during a crisis like what we what we're
experiencing currently and what I
understand is they're not equipped for
separation or for kovat but what they
would do is take some of the other
traffic off of the hospital so that they
can the hospitals on land would be able
to serve that purpose there's some
skeptics out there though and so I want
to give you a chance to respond to this
in Forbes it says to be blunt the ships
are being sent out to serve as little
more than a morale boost a Freddie photo
opportunity or a nice backdrop for a
political rally it's the wrong thing to
do in effective symbolism is the last
thing the nation needs right now what do
you make of that that's an outrageous
charge when you see firsthand what these
hospital ships do what the men and women
who serve on it do you'll see that what
they do is is a serious effort to take
care of those in need and when the when
the mercy goes to Seattle next week and
the comfort arrives in New York City in
a couple of weeks those individuals who
will be served there will become big
proponents I guarantee you after they
experience what these hospital ships do
they'll become big proponents for
everyone else to see that they serve a
tremendous purpose I'm very proud of
what what these ships do and what their
what everyone who serves on them deal
with the the the support that they
provide and I can't wait for more people
to become aware of that as well and
before you go quickly I want to put on
your other hat as a lawmaker and ask you
how quickly can people who are going to
receive checks folks who are in many
cases very desperate at this moment
looking forward to their future how
quickly will they get to Americans well
I hope it'll come very soon I mean I've
just had a very emotional week in my
district listening to constituents who
have been directly affected my warning
though is that these direct checks as
part of the third phase the third bill
this being that was just unveiled last
night in the Senate it still has a ways
to go it's being debated and put
together in the Senate the devil of the
detail the devil is in the details here
and there's still ways for it to go
before this becomes signed by the
President and those checks are dispersed
so stay tuned yeah we wish you all the
best in your work there and your work as
a reservist as well Thank You
congressman banks thank you